So, this seems like a really brain-dead way of doing things a bit. Maybe that's
good enough. We need to look at how we are actually using this procedure. If
we're going to use it for a human to tell how many days old they are, in an
interactive way, the fact that we have to wait 300th of a second for the answer
doesn't matter, that's plenty fast enough. Getting that down to less than a
100th of a second is not worth extra effort. If we are using it in a service,
that's doing this computation lots and lots of times for lots and lots of
different dates, well then, maybe it's not fast enough and it's worth putting time
and effort to doing something better. But we shouldn't put that time and effort
until we know that we need it to be faster. This point is important enough that
I want to put it in our guide to solving our problems. So, we have our first
steps, don't panic, make sure we understand the inputs and the outputs, works
through some examples by hand to think about how we would solve the problem
systematically. And then, try to develop a simple mechanical solution. And the
key here is simplicity, the simpler it is, the more likely we're going to be
able to program it correctly. Eventually, we might need to worry about making it
faster, but let's not worry about that until we have to.